la tensión se mantienen las calles de
Santa Cruz mientras el gobierno
boliviano no da su brazo a torcer y
mantiene el censo poblacional y de
vivienda para el 23 de marzo de 2024 el
presidente Luis Arce hizo un llamado a
la calma las bolivianas y bolivianos
queremos vivir en paz somos de la
cultura del diálogo y de la paz y por
eso llamamos a pacificar entre todas y
todos
el viernes se cumplían tres semanas de
protestas es el plazo que dio la
oposición de Santa Cruz para convocar el
censo poblacional en 2023 Durante este
tiempo ha habido cuatro muertos y más de
100 heridos
a los masistas se acaben la violencia a
nuestra gente
[Aplausos]
y que estén con el pueblo que es lo que
Todos queremos el último censo se
realizó en 2012 el gobierno de Luis
arcelo retrasó de 2023 a 2024 alegando
el parón de la pandemia además de
bastión opositor Santa Cruz es la
segunda ciudad del país y el principal
centro económico es la mayor receptora
de migración interna por lo que el
aumento de población le otorgaría más
recursos de hacerse el censo en 2023 la
región tendría tres diputados más en la
asamblea para las elecciones de 2025 Sin
embargo esta protesta se limita a Santa
Cruz y no tiene apoyo en el resto del
país tampoco es un apoyo masivo de forma
interna Ya que el movimiento al
socialismo es el segundo partido más
apoyado en la región
no nos dejan circular no nos dejan pagar
no deja de hacer nada Santa Cruz fue
también en 2019 el lugar desde donde se
ideó el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Evo Morales